US President Donald Trump declaring that
he will suspend immigration into the
United States via an executive order the
US president on Twitter said that's in
response to the corona virus pandemic
referring to curb 819 as the invisible
enemy mr. Trump added that he has to
protect American jobs the announcement
drew swift condemnation from some in the
u.s. Democratic Party there who accused
mr. Trump of distracting people from
what they described as his faulty
response to the outbreak John Henry has
more from Chicago the President issued
this tweet in the dark of night and he
seemed to do that for good reason he
could have made this announcement at his
daily news conference where he talks
about the corona virus and all of the
actions the administration is taking but
by issuing this mysterious tweet late on
a Monday night he gets the morning news
cycles where the newspapers in the
morning shows talk about what he's had
to say and then in the afternoon he gets
another round where he explains what his
policy is and then it gets digested and
analyzed again and the president wants
to show that he's doing something the
Centers for Disease Control just a month
ago in a little-known action issued an
order that allowed the United States to
stop people at the border who didn't
have the proper papers and because of
the pandemic that order allows them to
send people back summarily no court
hearing no chance for asylum they're
sent back automatically and now the
president is expanding that to include
any immigration from anywhere okay let's
bring in Thomas gifts he specializes in
u.s. politics he's a lecturer at
University College London Thomas welcome
back to the NewsHour here on al-jazeera
so he wants to safeguard 22 million jobs
that have already disappeared
what's he safeguarding well I think that
this is more about optics than it is
about economics there's certainly a
conceptual difference here between
shutting down borders from external
travel to many countries of course have
done to isolate contain the spread of
coca 19 and actually making substitute
reforms to immigration policy Trump does
insist that suspending immigration is
meant to protect jobs in the US
unemployment has escalated economists
can debate that but I think largely what
Trump is trying to do is exploit a
political opportunity here
of course stricter immigration policy
has been one of the president's marquee
issues since he entered the White House
is reflected by his national emergency
that he declared the build a us-mexico
border wall his effort to temporarily
ban immigration from Muslim majority
countries and so on and so I think that
this effort very much placed into that
narrative and he thinks that it's a
political winner among this conservative
base he tweeted in the middle of the
night his time Washington time does that
mean that we will see a not dissimilar
process to the process we've seen before
say when it comes to his foreign policy
on Twitter
there is a distinct rowing back and
somebody will give us clarity on this
over the coming couple of days that's
very possible I mean there is a lot of
uncertainty about what he actually meant
by the substance of his tweet just
because you know oftentimes these tend
to be so cryptic so we may see either a
walking back of this by some officials
with him in his administration or he may
decide to just press ahead with this as
he intended and so at this point there's
just a lot of uncertainty and a lot of
clarity that hopefully we'll be getting
more of in the coming days how do you
think this will go down with his base
well I think that this will go well
within his base because again this very
much fits into the broader political
narrative of a skeptical or a hard-line
stance toward integration but of course
it's also going to elicit a lot of
criticism from Democrats that they are
going to portray this as an instance of
xenophobic flame shifting they're
already suggesting that this is an
example Trump trying to find a scapegoat
for what they perceive as a mishandling
of the crisis so far and so it probably
is going to play well with among
conservatives and I think it's going to
play equally less well among liberals
which is consistent with this
polarization what we've seen in the
Trump presidency but give me Thomas if
my next question sounds slightly naive
and quite tabloid I guess in a way but
you know the pictures that are coming
out of America now yesterday
looking on social media we have nurses
wearing face masks and their ICU Nursing
Uniforms squaring off against
demonstrators protesters in trucks
wearing paramilitary outfits shouting
and pumping their horns are there parts
of America where Americans are beginning
to lose the plot over this well I think
that that's a really apt description at
the same time you know you're hoping
that some of these instances are are
more isolated than that of course
there's you know a tendency to kind of
focus on these on these particular
pictures these particular images but
certainly I think if anything kobe 19 is
further entrenching a lot of the
polarization that we've already
witnessed in the United States over the
past three half years over the trump
presidency and I think going forward
there was no reason to think that we're
going to see anything except for that
and he's mr. Trump do you think can he
can he maintain his position which he
seems to be squaring off against
individual states governors well he
certainly seems prepared to signal to
them that he will you know talking about
time to liberate I think it was three
states that he mentioned on Twitter what
four days ago now that's very strong
language very authoritarian language it
is quite provocative to say the least
and Trump continues to insist
essentially that he has full authority
over when and how the various states
open up in the coming potentially weeks
or months the reality however is that
under the Federalist u.s. system a lot
of these decisions that purview for
those kinds of choices are actually left
to the individual governor so there's
also going to be very much a political
battle over these questions as well
Thomas great talk to us fo many thanks